-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Fantastic.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden received
the daily intelligence
briefing this morning.
It was just, "So, they release
the Carter picture."
[ Laughter ]
How is this the first
we're hearing about the Bidens
being 40 feet tall?
[ Laughter ]
They look like
a ventriloquist act.
You know that dandelion pictur
from the other day?
That was an oak tree.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that President Biden
will deliver
the commencement address
later this month
at the U.S. Coast Guard
Academy graduation.
And, while we're on the subject,
is it too late to change
your Major?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Don't make me send you bac
to Scranton!
A White House announced
yesterday --
excuse me, the White House
or a White House.
[ Laughter ]
We should stop being so specific
about which one it is.
The White House announced
yesterday that President Biden
is raising the annual
refugee limit to 62,500.
Also rising?
Tucker Carlson's blood pressure.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
asked fifth graders
at an elementary school
in Virginia yesterday
what they wanted to be
when they grew up.
Said students,
"Covered by a healthcare pla
that isn't tied
to my employment."
Florida governor Ron DeSanti
yesterday suspended all
of the state's coronavirus
restrictions, and said,
"We are no longer
in a state of emergency,"
adding,
"but it's still Florida, so,
give it a couple of days."
Microsoft founder Bill Gates
announced yesterday
that he and his wife, Melinda,
will get a divorce,
after being married
for 27 years.
Apparently,
it was an accumulation
of lots of little things,
like how Bill would never
empty the recycling.
[ Laughter ]
That's what you get for hiring
people who used to work in IT.
[ Laughter ]
Researchers in Germany
recently named
a new bacteria that is linke
to lung parasites
after the Pokémon tool
Poké Balls
because they're a similar shape.
Said one German doctor --
[ German accent ] Bad news
Ve didn't catch 'em all.
[ Laughter ]
I should know.
I freestyled there.
The joke was not
for a German doctor
and, the last minute,
I was like, "You know what
Let's let it rip.
What's the worst
that could happen?"
And then, you saw
what the worst was.
[ Laughter ]
A man in England
was arrested last week
after a four miles per hou
police chase,
in a narrow boat on a canal,
that lasted for eight miles,
which means that,
by the time they caught him,
the statute of limitations
had run out.
Eight people who were involved
in the torch relay
for the Tokyo Olympic Game
have tested positive
for the coronavirus.
Well, it's hard news to hear
but, at least,
the contact tracing
will be easy.
And, finally,
according to a new report,
the number of customers
who subscribe
to AOL's dial-up service is,
"in the low thousands,"
which is also their average age.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue
everybody!